（はじめ）こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと！
（つる兄）つる兄です！
（はじめ）あっちょっと、こっち、こっちだったねｗｗｗ
（はじめ）こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと！
（つる兄）つる兄です！
（はじめ）あっ、こっちだわｗｗｗこっちだｗｗｗ
（はじめ）こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと！！
（つる兄）つる兄です！
ドシュッ！！！
（はじめ）説明しなさい何で俺の家に来たか
（はじめ）ほら、変なこと言ったら、SITみたいに炎上しちゃうからね
（つる兄）きちんと
（はじめ）なんで俺の家に来たかだよ
（つる兄）まず、明日ね東京で
（つる兄）ウッ～！
（つる兄）東京で、用事があるんですけど
（つる兄）その前にね、ちょっと静岡に寄って
（つる兄）あっ！
（つる兄）うっ！
（はじめ）うっ
（つる兄）東京に用事があるんで、
（つる兄）しゃちょーにも会いたくて静岡に
（はじめ）昔から知ってるよね、でも
（はじめ）４年前？
（つる兄）４年前です
（はじめ）４年前からか～
（はじめ）４年前から知ってるんだよ
（はじめ）YouTuber的には同期の、
（はじめ）高校生のつる兄と言います　（つる兄）そうです。こう見えても同・・・
（はじめ）ムームーTV知ってんのｗ
（はじめ）ラジオヤジは、持ってた
（はじめ）俺、ムームーTVとしか・・・
（はじめ）おはぎくん！
（つる兄）おはぎくん！
（２人）おはぎくん！
（はじめ）すいません、ちょっと今回はつる兄がね、無理矢理押しかけて来たので、
（はじめ）７歳差でしょｗヤバいじゃんｗ
（はじめ）お父さんだよ
（つる兄）お父さん？
（つる兄）お父さんではねぇかｗ
（はじめ）つる兄の悩みを聞きたいんだけど・・・
（はじめ）同期としてさぁ
（はじめ）なんかこう、悩み無いの？
（つる兄）そうですね、でも本音言うと、
（つる兄）もっと観てもらいですねみんなに・・・
（はじめ）売名チャンス★
（つる兄）売名していいっすかｗ
（はじめ）売名どうぞ！
（つる兄）ど・・・
（はじめ）というわけで今日はですね～
（はじめ）まあ、すごいシンプルなんですけども～
（はじめ）簡単に言いますと、僕よく動画中で、くしゃみをすると思うんですけども
（はじめ）動画じゃないとこでもするでしょ
（つる兄）さっきも４連発ぐらい・・・
（はじめ）めっちゃしてる・・・
（はじめ）４連発は盛った
（はじめ）くしゃみで、いかにその面白いくしゃみができるか
（つる兄）面白いくしゃみね・・・
（はじめ）くしゃみマスター的なとこあるから～
（つる兄）ありますね～
（はじめ）まず見本を見せてね
（はじめ）面白いくしゃみの方法ねちょっとね見せて上げようと思います
（はじめ）フェチ！
（つる兄）うあっ！
（はじめ）微妙だったね今の・・・
（はじめ）ハ～
（はじめ）あれ？声だけでた
（はじめ）おっすごいぞ、今声だけ出た
（はじめ）くしゃみを音エネルギーに変換したからね、今
（つる兄）ハ～って言いましたよｗｗ
（はじめ）ブラックバス！
（つる兄）バシュ～ン
（はじめ）ｗｗｗ
（はじめ）はっほぉぉう！
（はじめ）目を開けてました
（つる兄）あ～
（はじめ）オープニングアイズって言う技です。今の
（はじめ）今日はくしゃみ講座だね
（はじめ）この動画を見てるみなさんも是非ね、
（はじめ）その、面白いくしゃみって言うのを覚えてね、
（はじめ）学校の人気者になってみてください
（つる兄）いや、授業中にいきなりやったらもう人気者ですよ
（はじめ）だめだわ！
（はじめ）ハクション！
（つる兄）うわぁ！
（はじめ）決まったぜ
（はじめ）スプラッシュだ
（つる兄）ｗｗｗ
（はじめ）覚えたかｗｗｗ
（つる兄）さすがですｗｗ
（はじめ）ただし、このレベルはすごいよ
（はじめ）もう、Sランクの技だからね
（つる兄）結構飛びましたよｗ
（はじめ）結構飛びましたねｗｗ
（はじめ）んふっ！
（つる兄）んほっ！
（はじめ）必殺、だるま落としだ！
（はじめ）ｗｗ
（はじめ）w顔ふざけすぎｗｗ
（はじめ）はっ
（２人）ハ～～～～～～～～～～ッ
デデン！
（２人）ヘクション！
（２人）そばにいたいよ 君のために出来・・・
（はじめ）ハッホイ！
（つる兄）ほんとすごいですよ、それ
（はじめ）クッシャッン！
（はじめ）だろ？
（はじめ）ブンブッ
（はじめ）ｗｗｗ
（はじめ）BEET BOXです
（つる兄）ｗｗ
（はじめ）ハゥブルルゥゥゥ
（つる兄）き～た～ないｗｗ
（はじめ）ウォーターハザードだ
（つる兄）www
（はじめ）んっ！んふっ！
（はじめ）ハッ！ブシュッ
（つる兄）ンッ！ブ～！
（はじめ）ブァッフ～
（はじめ）ハックシュ
（はじめ）つる兄覚えとけ
（はじめ）真のくしゃみプレイヤーは
（はじめ）何ででも出せる
（はじめ）ハッビュッシュッ
（つる兄）すげ～
（はじめ）ハックシュン
（はじめ）ハッホン
（はじめ）さぁ、つる兄見せてくれ
（はじめ）俺がお前に授けた
（はじめ）くしゃみの伝説を
（はじめ）受け継ぐんだ！さぁ見せてやれ
（はじめ）お前の真の力
（はじめ）お前はここで何を学んだ
（はじめ）解き放て
（はじめ）体の不思議
（はじめ）生命の神秘
（はじめ）くしゃみという名の
（はじめ）生理現象！
（つる兄）ヴァ～
（はじめ）馬鹿たれか！
～♪ED♪～